bonsoir salut qu'à saint clair c'est
vrai qu'on peut s'interroger sur ses
propos d' emmanuel macron qui clairement
appuyé un petit peu là où ça fait mal et
dans le même temps cherchent désormais
l'appaisement quelle est votre lecture
avoue
t il il ya deux deux problématiques
peut-être même 3 qui s'entrechoquent la
première c'est une relation de longue
date complexe tant du minet avec le
pouvoir algérien et peut-être même plus
largement avec la la la société
algérienne qui pour une large part à
tisser des liens extrêmement forts avec
une partie de la diaspora qui vit
aujourd'hui en france la question
mémorielle est effectivement une
question
centrale mais elle n'est pas aussi
importante et c'est le deuxième point
finalement de crispation elle n'est pas
aussi importante que veut bien le faire
croire emmanuel macron qui a une
obsession
mémorielle doublé qu'une obsession de la
repentance donc finalement sur cette
question là on se rend bien compte que
il met la question mémorielle à toutes
les sauces et c'est ce mot de rente
mémorielle et extrêmement insultant à
l'égard du pouvoir politique
ap algérien et il ne traduit rien
d'autre que l'obsession macro nien pour
la question de la mémoire le troisième
problème qui est un véritable problème
en soi est une question de régulation
des flux migratoires
avec les pays du maghreb mais en réalité
est une question qui se pose plus
largement pour chaque état et cette
question là si elle est aujourd'hui si
mal perçu c'est que emmanuel macron a
effectué un revirement à 180° pendant
quatre ans il n'a absolument pas voulu
se préoccuper des flux entrants en
france et à six mois de la
présidentielle parce qu'eric zemmour
vient taper très fort dans la
fourmilière parce que la droite se
droitise encore plus l air mais
également marine le pen est bien
emmanuel macron pose un acte extrêmement
fort et mal compris parce qu'il n'a pas
été accompagnée des mesures
diplomatiques nécessaires prévenir les
gouvernements marocain j'ai rien
tunisien expliqué que des circonstances
particulières ça n'a pas échappé je le
note à la presse algérienne qui n'a pas
manqué de répéter dans ses colonnes que
c'était bien parce qu'elle manuel macron
et est en campagne qu'il réagissait
comme ça aujourd'hui clairement les
choses vont quand même loin pour une
sortie peut-être électoraliste à 6 mois
donc de la présidentielle vous l'avez
rappelé lg qui décident de le rappeler
son ambassadeur qui qui ferme son espace
aérien aux avions militaires français je
jusqu'où ça ça peut aller cette petite
crispation voir crise diplomatique
je ne pense pas que ça ira très loin
vous avez vu que le président macron a
déjà donné des signes d'apaisement il
n'est pas un président à vouloir taper
très fort du poing sur la table en
revanche il il a manifestement manqué de
sagesse on ne parle pas de cette façon
là même dans une réunion
qui n'est pas directement diffusé sur
les réseaux sociaux ou
télévisées il ya besoin encore une fois
de de diplomatie où on se rend bien
compte qu'ils placent le président
tebboune avec il dit avoir des relations
cordiales dans une situation impossible
où il loue l'isolent finalement de ceux
de cette caste politico militaire qu'il
dénonce et qu'ils condamnent vous voyez
bien que là les propos d'emmanuel
m'apprend sont absolument intenable donc
il fallait qu'il fasse un petit
rétropédalage il l'a fait aujourd'hui on
va rester à mon avis dans cette
situation de crispation parce que la
vraie question qui gênent alger c'est la
question des visas est juste titre mais
il va y avoir de part et d'autre
probablement à plus ou moins long terme
un certain nombre de signaux positifs
qui vont être envoyés comme ça se passe
à chaque fois est qui et qui vont
apaiser c'est cette crise parmi ces
signaux justement cela concernera les
les les visas et dans ce cas et macro
aura fait son effet d'annonce sans le
suivre vraiment d'effet derrière il est
possible effectivement il est possible
que emmanuel macron tienne cette ligne
un peu ferme jusqu'à le mois de juin au
mois d'avril prochain que finalement ils
cèdent vous savez qu'il assignait ce
pacte de marrakech qui normalise le
principe des des flux migratoires on a
longtemps dit que c'était une
orchestration de migration outrance
n'est pas le cas en revanche il ya bel
et bien une législation qui tente à
normaliser le principe de la migration
si j'ai envie de partir de chez moi dit
le texte eh bien il faut que les états
accompagne mon souhait de migrer massa
va dans le sens d'un d'une ouverture aux
pays du maghreb et aux op aux personnes
qui sont désireuses de venir en france
et pas est pas là inverse donc là
finalement emmanuel macron est
complètement à contre-courant de ski son
logiciel son adn politique il ya fort à
parier effectivement que une fois les
élections présidentielles passées il il
relâche les vannes justement cette
affaire des visas qui concerne également
les marocains et les tunisiens on peut
imaginer la même crispation avec ces
deux pays également où l'histoire est
encore plus particulière avec l'algérie
elle est plus particulier vous avez
raison la crispation existe déjà
à rabat il y as au maroc des détentions
7,7 cette fermeture a été mal perçu
ensuite il va falloir voir dans le
détail qui elle concerne vous avez vu qu
emmanuel macron sous l'angle de la
boutade à a dit que les étudiants et les
milieux économiques ne seraient pas
touchés et que finalement ils mettraient
la pression davantage sur les milieux
d'affaires les milieux diplomatiques et
sert à ce qui était encore une fois mal
venu mais ce qui montre quand même
le l'intérêt qu'y emmanuel macron porte
aux échanges avec les pays du maghreb en
matière économique et estudiantine en
tunisie on a que 30 % de réduction ddd
vise à comparer à 50% pour le maroc et
l'algérie il y a dans tout le maghreb
finalement une histoire depuis 20 à 30
ans extrêmement forte d'aller de retour
avec la france est cette logique de
restriction des visas s'inscrit vraiment
dans une politique de droitisation
globale de la france on a vu que même
manuel valls revient sur de façon
critique sur son bilan et parle de la
nécessité de repenser le droit d'asile
de repenser l'accueil des familles
d'immigrés de conditionner l'accueil à
l'obtention d'un travail donc on trouve
bien que cette question de l'immigration
est centrale dans le débat politique
français emmanuel macron ne peut pas
l'éviter donc il va falloir
diplomatiquement expliquer ça aux pays
du maghreb merci beaucoup frédéric
sinclair pour cet éclairage ce soir